hey guys welcome to awesome comics
I'm Ayanna and Walter and Porter are
here with me as usual and we're here
with a special friend of mine today
Orion coolie
so guys we're bringing you a really
special episode of awesome comics we're
gonna do a train like a superhero
episode specifically talking about
Captain America we're going to go over
some moves and some training and then do
a little fight sequence at the end for
you
great well as we know Captain America is
you know has amazing strength speed and
fortitude a full window from Marvel he
can travel run about 50 miles per hour
at his peak about 3500 we also know that
he has 20 times the reflexes of the
average human and is eight times
stronger than someone in peak physical
condition so that's that's pretty strong
yes they give you perspective on the
spider-man that 80 times a humanity and
they say that Hulk is a hundred thousand
times in humans so something to think
about
so it puts them in the heavy hitters as
far as the superhero world that we're in
but the strong is there somebody to be
continued with for sure but he's also
mortal and you know we can live through
a lot of stuff he can survive a lot of
things he has incredible ability to
wreak to heal when it comes down to it
he needs to not be shot please not be
hit by a knife um so that's why the show
comes into play
so the shield's a great piece of
property have on hand it's a great
weapon as it were it's also meant
primarily for defense and we know that
the shield has been around as far as our
civilizations go oh man well 10,000
years give or take the course familiar
with Spartans and the way they use their
shields from the wonderful movie 300 but
also we know from our history right I
know that we're not a huge sack
Schneider fans always but that was a
pretty big film solid shield work in
that movie but when you're using a
shield like this this is a prop shield
this shield is made out of aluminum the
actual shell that this was to be made of
steel would be about eight pounds
heavier we did bring some of those
shields today to play with they're made
of steel on the so the shield in when we
use this as a weapon
and as a form is all about your whole
body in movies nowadays especially the
ket America being so strong you see him
just move his arm around the shield's
doing this thing authentically in
history and period
it's more of your Center in your core
doing all the work for you there's no
way you're gonna get out the ancient
battlefield by using your arm just to
block all day long your arms gonna get
too tired to be effective um we in
Western society are very bicep based
when it comes down to it any warrior
knows that it's your core that does the
job boxers know this and you see this in
baseball - you don't swing with your
arms you swing with your hips it's the
same thing applied for your shield so I
want my shield remover there I need to
throw my hips and let my shield move I
want to block myself in here for my hips
that let my shield move right contrary
to what we see in the film were just
WAMP of course he is superhuman so
there's that so there are a couple of
different ways that were to take a look
at using the shield cat America has all
kinds of ways of using that we're gonna
focus on four just so we can make sure
we get this out it's a sync pattern so
the thing we're talking about today is
about shoving the shield the idea of
taking a massive force and moving that
force away to create some distance he
does this on a lot of his films another
one took a little bit of what we call
the bash or the smash what happens when
he swings the shield and how do we swing
that effectively finally look at what
happens when he hits you with the edge
of the shield which is nasty business
and then we're trying to take a look at
the old shield throw and see how that
goes soon Captain America uses the
shield shove it seems quite effortless
the fact that matter is it wouldn't be
if for any normal human to shove off
that many opponents um that's gonna take
a lot of work and said I'll be firing
off that back hip as we know from again
for me kind of martial practice that if
I'm engaging my left front
I'm always powered off my back leg to it
so my right thighs engaged I'm using my
hips you're going to try taking the
stance here I want to put the shield in
and we're gonna push up it's not gonna
be about your left arm it's not gonna be
about your left thigh something about
your right leg you know dig in it's nice
to say and um and judo I'm gonna use the
earth to move you okay so I'm gonna push
through the earth and then have the
earth push you off not meat or to push
you off does that make sense yeah right
so that's the basic concept we're never
dig in feel that what a push off and
then step in and Hammurabi cool
so next we took a look at the bash or
the smash I like to point out the fact
that we did some science before we uh
you know we're all the back doing some
science you know we feel real good the
most story is that we found us
things asking some various physicist and
some scientist that I work with about
what would happen if Captain America
hits you with his shield your basic kind
of strike as it were
we know professional boxer when they
swing into an uppercut or into a stomach
trench to the chest hits you with about
500 pounds of force that's enough to
easily break a rib cage
remember the Captain America is eight
times stronger than a professional boxer
so when Captain America smashes you kind
of casually with his shield it's going
to be an incredible amount of impact
most likely if you're a henchman you're
probably not getting off the ground
again that said I did talk to my friends
about this this isn't a matter about her
throws as well as our edge work he does
have 20 times the agility and dexterity
of an average human - so if you think
about this when you're playing out with
you know kids in the park you're playing
your I don't know your LARPing per se
maybe maybe a LARP maybe you do that
maybe I do don't don't judge so um and
you're playing the kids you get your
nerve swords you know when you're
playing with a four-year-old you don't
hit them as hard as you hit you know
your friends or your age so it's
possible that maybe he doesn't kill
everybody all the time because he can
you know finesse that a little bit fast
but I've been watching this movies they
look pretty dead yeah yeah all right so
the bash again is gonna come cat America
does it entirely off his arm he doesn't
really use his core he throws it right
off his left bicep boom right but we
want to make a little more authentic we
also want to make us think we can do
again and again and again forever and
ever and ever so same idea I'm gonna
rotate my hips back and he's my hips to
open it'll maximize my impact now of
course the cat America did this most
likely
whoever's knit may the full fury of his
uh fury full fury of his fury full force
of his fury is gonna be knocked into
oblivion
when we do it it would just truly truly
suck so let's try this let's kind of
take a look for the difference for this
do it don't use your head just try
throwing your right arm around it maybe
do like five six times go ahead try it
out yes mm-hmm
keep it going for about an hour that's
no problem so that's the idea of just
using that left arm you've got to
remember though this is an ancient
weapon from not more civilized time and
I always like to point out on a teaching
shield this is what
and as someone had to use four hours not
four minutes all right all the work the
Captain America does he's done in like
five minutes per battle imagine though
if he's on that battlefield and it's
nonstop real it's a live load in the
first Avengers a non-stop hour after our
combat you're gonna have to use your
core there's even Captain America strong
as he's in half uses core right to get
through it I point out that the battle
of thickness River from the second Punic
War Hannibal it was eight hours long
just sword and shield with 80,000 dead
no Briggs no timeouts no bathroom breaks
so for the thing about all right solicit
get in this feel the difference of using
our hips
it's weird I think a wider stance when
it's drop into our hips when we're
bringing our body back towards our right
side with roll with our left okay do you
feel the difference in the ease of a C
or to do this yeah yeah so switch where
I go for if we want to be cat America we
still want to go for ease you know he's
got to find a whole bunch of Hydra guys
by far the most dangerous aspect Captain
America's shield
he's his edge we believe it to be about
a centimeter and as far as width goes
and it's shield weighs about 12 pounds
but the edge is how we kill people if
you ever see cat America hit any one
with the edge of a shield you can
automatically assume they are dead
because even a typical human hit
somebody with editor shield they're
probably a real problem have real
problems
you know member to understand that the
human body can only take so much impact
some parts extremely fragile for example
your collarbone can only take about four
pounds of impact before it's going to
break it's true the other thing we can
do is they talk about how much the
pressure takes to break a sternum you
all times see cat America hit people
with the edge of the shield somewhere in
the chest
it's 960 pounds of pressure to crush the
sternum entirely we know this from the
from steering wheel impacts and studies
about what happens to the body when
they're hit by uh by that kind of
speeding that kind of power when it only
takes again about 460 pounds to break
all the ribs apart okay so something to
think about
same idea for the shield we see him move
it like this and that's that's you know
a lot of left arm he's got arms
mr. Evans has huge arms all right that
said we are average people with average
arms we want to make sure that just like
we
from the bashing video that we use our
whole body so we're gonna take our body
a normal profile
alright left foot in front as it were
we're gonna think about swing it like a
baseball bat sideways whenever your way
back and unwind hard now the trick is
this we've remembered that there's gonna
be quite a bit of an Ursa on the outside
of this and we don't want to swing so
hard that we pop our own collarbone out
right or that we take our arm out of
socket okay or we just wrench our arm
around so it's here and then send it
like to be specific if I just completely
open I'm gonna go past my shoulder axis
and can torque my back okay that's not
fun no one likes that so here we go
cocked and send it to the camera boom
yeah so what we have is this edge making
a lot of impact and the question is can
it really do that much damage only one
way to find out
so we're about to see if we can indeed
take the edge of this to a watermelon to
see what happens now remember let's just
talk a couple seconds about the
watermelon as a forensic topic as a
problem can use the human skull is again
basically the 80% fluid all right
the brain has a brain tissue around it
there the skull and it's thickest point
it's doing a centimeter thick right it's
not too thick the watermelon is about an
inch thick so there's a little
difference there but of course has a bit
of a give the one thing we're missing to
make this proper would be skin in a
perfect world we cover this like in a
fruit roll-up that would allow for skin
it's gonna have slippage and that's
gonna change your impact upon what
you're hitting
that said it should just be a really
good time so we're gonna see what
happens take it away
sure that was awesome watermelon yellow
yeah I mean but well very little effort
at all to think about if you really put
some torque into it how much damage you
could do again this is a pretty decent
human skull stimulant it's okay it's not
awesome it's not perfect but it gets the
job done
can't America hits you with the edge of
his shield at a moderate velocity you're
going to blow up my favorite thing that
America does is throw a shield we can
talk about the Boomer and fist but more
in physics if we wants you but the fact
matter is it's pretty difficult to
boomerang a shield it's not impossible
it can be done but that's not today at
all today let's just dial it back let's
talk about throwing a shield it is my
personal philosophy that if you're not
cat in America you should never throw
your shield let's talk about projection
weapons this is not one of them this is
not a weapon projectile weapon this is
not a weapon that you won't need to get
rid of it's there for a reason
because you're mortal and this should
block the bad things right this needs to
stay here I want to keep it there we
also talked about the head
hagh jump once my doing that okay okay
second so we're throwing the shield is
from a Marshall perspective and
extremely bad idea because remember the
cat America can receive damage just like
anyone else um so it leaves you
vulnerable to attack from all the guys
who are shooting their machine guns at
your face which is not awesome but that
said it's pretty fun and it looks great
so let's take a look at whether or not
we can throw the shield at just at all
to start with the question is of course
we can accuracy entirely dependable run
away to throw our shield in scale and
these shields only weigh about about
seven and a half pounds it's not the end
of the world we know what a cat in
America's shield weighs 12 pounds but
it's 12 pounds of possibly an elastic
substance so vibranium as it were so we
don't really know how it's gonna fly in
the air when we can imagine as probably
something similar to this basic shield
so what do you think should give it a
shot let's try it let's try it out one
you want to give it a shot or should I
give it a shot you do it first okay I'll
do first and I'm gonna not put my full
force on it
undergoing the theory that Kenton more
custom Orica Captain America America
underneath the view that Kent America
through his shield at full force we
actually have no idea how fast he can
throw the fastest speed ball thrown in
history is 105 miles an hour okay I
can't imagine what would happen if Karen
had to Kent America through a shield at
you had 105 miles an hour he would we
know according to the comics he can cut
through helicopter tails
we know he can cut through brick walls
if you're a human and you're hit by
Captain America's shield 105 miles an
hour there's gonna be nothing of you
left right Darth Maul eminent alright so
that said we're going to assume that he
modifies his throat he's neither full
force this because he's getting America
so let's go underneath the idea that he
is throwing at 40 miles an hour my
physics is my physicist friend and I sat
down and worked some equations out at 40
miles an hour he's treating 920 joules
of energy all right and he is going to
be doing it up to 2020 6,000 pounds of
pressure upon impact remember before we
talked about what it takes to crack the
the human body open and break it apart
and destroy it at 960 pounds of pressure
turn them just to City rates right at
four and sixty pounds of pressure our
ribs all just break out okay so 25,000
pounds of pressure at 43 miles an hour
he should easily be able to take down a
helicopter tail right so we're assuming
that if we don't see Poe cut in half who
must be throwing somewhere around 20
miles an hour right maybe maybe Ted
maybe he's throwing it in slow motion we
don't really know we also know that
we're gonna lose a velocity at the
further it goes right so we're losing
basically about 10 percent velocity the
further distance we have to throw so
we're going to try chucking these
shields over here and we're going to see
one just how smooth would be the release
and two maybe now how far I'm pretty
sure that she could throw it all the way
into the costumes over there but I'm
gonna go for right in front of him
hopefully it's my target
so Kevin America does he is a righty so
he's probably Dukakis shield on his left
side
what's up costume rock contest we're not
caber tossing we're not the Scottish
Highland Games but give it a shot see
what you think all right more that way
than that way yeah but I still wouldn't
want to get hit by that right now if
someone said hail Ryan
please go catch that shield with your
body Emily not doing that right okay so
the question is can we hit a target
let's find out awesome
all right so we're gonna give it a shot
here against our garbage cans stunt
double because we couldn't get any rest
of the guys to stand there and let us
hit them with shield supporter nope but
again his helper henchman over there is
doomed just doomed let's give it a shot
for the winds what I'm fine that I'm
doing right now is we're releasing the
shield
I'm definitely throwing and releasing
with her my right but I'm targeting with
my left hand so it's interesting to
think about him being right-handed
because we target on the left side which
also means that most likely as he throws
this his target eyes and change to his
left side so it's possible that he
actually might throw it here to target
with the right but again we don't seem
do that
yeah
I can do this all day that was so much
fun you guys
thanks so much for walking thanks I Ryan
for joining us um we always look at your
comments so please let us know below if
you'd like to see anything else like
this I've got some a few ideas ticking
away in my brain of other people we
could do next but if you have an idea of
what you'd like for us to do next please
let us know down below thank you for
liking this video thank you for
subscribing and as always you can find
us on facebook at awesome show a awesome
comics show you slash awesome comic show
and you can find me on facebook as well
facebook.com slash diana wade or on
twitter Walter where can we find you on
twitter at awesome underscore walter
porter how about you facebook.com slash
awesome porter well that makes it easy
and alright you can tell us a little bit
about yourself and where we can find you
that great you know so I live in
Chicagoland and I'm a fight director but
the primary work I do is for a
not-for-profit company called edge of
Orion and we work with marginalized
communities so when I'm not doing
something work when I'm not doing fight
direction a lot of times you can find me
out in the burbs working with people who
special needs doing huge theater
projects and working on the inclusion in
our community so you can learn more
about that at edge of Ryan comm we're
also on Twitter at edge of Orion as the
handle and yeah cool an importer is new
take it away with our Pick of the Week
this week we have a couple here issues 1
& 2 of Steve Rogers Captain America hail
Hydra anyway I'm sure you all know about
the controversy with Steve Rogers at the
end of issue 1 saying hail Hydra well
this u2 came out and it says hail Hydra
the secret history of Steve Rogers
revealed now basically I don't want to
give any spoilers I'm not gonna give any
spoilers but it explains why he's doing
that it has something to do with koubek
the sentient cube Cosmic Cube that came
to life she's the reason why he has
powers now so it goes into a little
history that and explains everything so
moving forward it's gonna be interesting
to see where Kat goes with this new
Hydra s personality and how everybody
deals with that and what actually
happens so I'm looking forward to seeing
more of this series I wasn't against cap
being hi
I thought it was an interesting turn of
events and even though everybody was
super pissed off I knew this was
basically comic clickbait so I figured
okay something's gonna be pretty pretty
decent explaining it so I like it it's a
good read it's very new territory for
Captain America as we all know so I'm
gonna come in to continue reading thanks
again for joining us here are some
comics
for myself and everyone here we'll see
you on the next page